he did this video where he gave this
this incredible truly life-changing
surgery so that blind people could see
to a thousand people it's cataract
surgery to cure their blindness here's
just a little snippet in this video
we're hearing a thousand people's
blindness
it's gonna be crazy it's that simple
they can see again
[Music]
you pay for my surgery yes but seriously
you know here's ten thousand dollars
we're just getting started we still have
980 lives left to change but then the
haters come out and there's this this
Cascade uh this endless Cascade of
people on YouTube going after him for
this he's a grifter and everything else
and then mainstream media goes after him
too check out this article from Forbes
The Babylon B had a great take on this
thing because they saw the controversy
this is just perfect sad YouTuber Mr B
spends million gearing blind people when
he could have sent another tank to
Ukraine absolutely perfect
foreign
[Music]